evening and welcome to fox news prime
time
[Music]
i'm jesse waters independence day is
this weekend while most americans are
getting ready to celebrate freedom
joe biden's busy celebrating himself
specifically
the great economy he claims he created
our commander-in-chief says cookouts are
16 cents cheaper than last year and
that's proof that his economic plan is
working
because of joe bags of potato chips are
one percent cheaper
and lemonade which is water mixed with
powder
is down two percent compared to a year
when all of our supply chains were
strained from a global pandemic
but what the white house failed to
mention is everything
that's more expensive the biden team
just hand-picked a few select items that
are
pennies cheaper than last year overall
grocery store prices are up big that
includes items like meat
poultry fish eggs strawberries cookies
hamburger buns and that delicious potato
salad
so you can enjoy biden's prosperous
economy if you stick to a very limited
menu
and if you really want to capitalize on
those gains
make sure to either walk or bike to your
family's cookout
because gas prices are at a seven year
high
our white house correspondent peter
ducey asked jen saki if this is a
concern
she didn't really seem to think so
does the white house think that 16 cents
off a barbecue
has more of an impact on people's lives
than gas being
a dollar more this time at this point i
would say
if you don't like hot dogs you may not
care of the reduction of costs
you don't have to like hot dogs
joining me now stephen miller former
senior advisor and director of speech
writing to president trump and founder
of
america first legal and austin goldsbee
former chief economist for president
obama quick fact check on sake miller
hot dog prices are at a seven year high
so just right there alone they're lying
why lie about food prices
stephen it is the one thing the american
people know
very well because they're actually
shopping joe biden has a chef in the
white house that cooks for him
he doesn't shop i think it just
underscores how
hopelessly out of touch high-ranking
staffers are at the white house
the president himself his senior aides
from the travails and difficulties faced
by ordinary americans
i mean the point about gas prices
especially gas
is a dollar more expensive per gallon
than it was one year ago under president
trump
think about what that means for working
families especially people who have to
commute
every single day you're going to pay an
extra 20 30
a week in gas prices but we're supposed
to be grateful that maybe
although their numbers don't seem right
to me that you're going to save 16 cents
on your barbecue
it's out of touch it's insulting it's
offensive
and frankly it's unserious
yeah goldsby why lie about food prices
we fact-checked them i mean everything's
up milk bananas strawberries coffee beer
wine
bread steak bacon ham rice pasta it's
all up
hold on so why are they trying to trick
the american people that they have all
of a sudden
food prices when it's the opposite i
don't know if you i don't know if you
misspoke
or you you aren't embarrassed did you
say that you make your lemonade by
mixing water with powder
you don't actually use lemons yeah i i
i am really i thought you were from
philly i mean you gave that that's not
lemonade that philly we use the powder
buddy i mean that is nice you should
know that
go ahead so go ahead here's the thing
i always hate getting in discussions
about prices i don't think they should
have said
anything about barbecue prices because
it just invites
well if the price of corn is down what
about the price of salami you know
that's up i think the bigger picture
that they
they sort of missed the boat on is the
jobs
number came out this morning we added
850
000 jobs in a single month wages for
ordinary american workers are growing
faster than they have in decades
that's a message they should have stuck
on i don't think they should have made
it about food prices because there are
food prices that are definitely up
and stephen i am sure you would just say
that president trump
basically built a strong foundation for
this economy then got a
vaccine in the same year the pandemic
hit and is responsible for creating this
rebound and now all these republican
governors
slash this 300 unemployment bonus that
got people off the couch back into the
workforce
i think the republicans can take a lot
of credit for this economic rebound
well a few points and i'm sure austin
would agree
the number one factor at the heart
of our economy's current ability to
produce jobs at all
is the operation warp speed vaccine
that's the center of
everything point one secondly if biden
had just gotten out of the way
if he hadn't threatened to raise taxes
if he hadn't threatened to spend us into
oblivion if he hadn't triggered
inflation we'd be at four percent
unemployment right now
not almost six percent unemployment and
finally
and finally because of the inflation is
taking place because of
the hike in the price of gasoline
whatever poultry gains people are seeing
in their in their earnings is being
totally dwarfed
by inflation the rising cost of goods
and their loss of purchasing power
so the purchasing power of the american
consumer
and their savings are being steadily
eroded under the biden economy
yeah the wage growth is shot by the rise
in prices of gasoline
absolutely now let's go back a few
months ago joe biden said hey we might
not even be able to
celebrate this weekend we might not even
be able to barbecue because
us bad little boys and girls aren't
getting vaccinated let's listen
do our part we do this together
by july the 4th there's a good chance
you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
that doesn't mean large events with lots
of people together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together
so austin i didn't hit the 70 percent
number i mean that's fine i think people
were barbecuing on memorial day
probably last memorial day too so what
do you make of that
prediction that didn't really add up
well you're right they've deployed the
vaccine and done better
in the slowing the rate of the virus
than they even thought back when they
made that
so we got to 68 with the vaccine
you add on top of that the fact that
there was a decent chunk of the country
that actually
caught the virus so they probably have
some immunity
and in a lot of the states i think we're
in a pretty good spot
i mean as i say when you add 850
000 jobs in a single month when wages
are
up it's almost 7 for the year far
more than prices are up it's not true
that purchasing power is down
it's up it's why if you look in the
surveys consumer confidence
is at a an unprecedented high
and it's higher than we were under the
trump economy i mean i think you guys
need to
i i see the operation warp speed was
excellent
that was a bright spot in the trump
administration and
and he deserves credit for pushing warp
speed
the deployment of the vaccine was also
critical that credit
austin i thank you for that and the
deployment of the vaccine and it's
and it's generally so important so you
know
i want to take a moment to compliment
you because it's good of you to say that
and i thank you for saying that and the
speech that was played to president
biden his famous gloomy speech about the
reopening that was never going to happen
was notable for the fact that it never
once thanked president trump for the
vaccine
that is responsible for everything that
is possible right now
the tragedy and i will repeat this the
tragedy is
that if joe biden had just gotten out of
the way this economy would have taken
off
like a rocket ship again we'd be at four
percent unemployment right now
wages would be up 15 remember we're
coming back from a lockdown from a
pandemic
because of the vaccine but the but the
threat in tax hikes
the increased regulation the shutting
down of american energy
the opening of our borders and this
spending spree
is holding back our economy and holding
back working people
and yes the price of gasoline for
working people is erasing whatever wage
gains they're seeing
that is a fact it's not awesome
unfortunately we have to go
i i we do have to run i'm sure you agree
with everything steven said though
thank you guys for coming on we really
appreciate it and
enjoy the hot dogs enjoy the hot dogs
this is bad
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else